You're ruining my clickbait, Ben. So the question is, what do we call this algorithm? What do we call this one algorithm? Yeah, what is this? Is there an umbrella term for scans and folds? Scaffold. Oh man, now we've got Scanduction and we've got Scaffold. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 131, recorded on May 16th, 2023. My name is Connor.
你在毁我的点击诱饵，本。所以问题是，我们该怎么称呼这个算法？我们怎么称呼这单个算法？对，这是什么？扫描和折叠有没有一个总括的术语？Scaffold。天哪，现在我们有了Scanduction，还有Scaffold。欢迎来到ADSP播客，第131期，录制于2023年5月16日。我是康纳。
Today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue the conversation with Ben Dean and Tristan Brindle and discuss what is the one algorithm to rule them all. Anyways, all right, wrapping now, finally, part one. which is what the real reason we've collected this algorithmic minds is to talk about the title of this episode will be one algorithm to rule them all and this idea came out of the interview that we had with tristan where we were having a discussion of what is the quote-unquote you know root algorithm to rule all algorithms or what is the most sort of fundamental algorithm that all other algorithms can be implemented in terms of or is, does there even one that exists? We're going to talk about that for the remainder of this recording.
今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们继续与本·迪恩和特里斯坦·布林德尔对话，讨论什么是统领一切的单一算法。不管怎样，好吧，现在终于要进入第一部分了，这也是我们聚集这些算法大师的真正原因，本集节目的标题将是“统领一切的单一算法”，这个想法源于我们对特里斯坦的采访，当时我们在讨论什么是所谓的统领所有算法的“根”算法，或者所有其他算法都可以基于它来实现的最基础的算法是什么，或者说，这样的算法真的存在吗？在本次录音的剩余时间里，我们将讨论这个问题。
So I think maybe what we should all do first, without any explanation, one by one we'll go around and we just get to say the name of the one algorithm and we'll go from there. Okay, cool. I'll go first. Reduce.
所以我想也许我们首先应该做的，是在没有任何解释的情况下，依次说出那个单一算法的名字，然后我们再接着往下聊。好的，太棒了。我先来。Reduce。
All right. Bryce says reduce. We'll go to Tristan next. Zip, fold, while. Zip, fold, while. We'll go to Ben next. I'll take the side that I reached out to you about. Scan while.
好的。布莱斯说是reduce。接下来轮到特里斯坦。Zip, fold, while。Zip, fold, while。接下来轮到本。我选那个我联系过你的那个。Scan while。
Alright, so we've got reduce, we've got zip fold while, we've got scan while. Now that I'm actually coming around myself... Reaction from Tristan. I think... I think I'm... I think I'll also say reduce,
好吧，所以我们有了reduce，我们有了zip fold while，我们有了scan while。现在我自己也想通了……来自特里斯坦的反应。我想……我想我……我想我也选reduce，
although my mind can be changed. Good man. But I think reduce is where it's at. All right. Who wants to respond first to... I feel like Tristan has thoughts on what Ben said, and Ben has thoughts on what Tristan said. Well, zip fold while seems like a bit of
尽管我的想法可能会改变。好样的。但我认为reduce才是核心。好吧。谁想首先对……我觉得特里斯坦对本说的话有想法，本对特里斯坦说的话也有想法。嗯，zip fold while看起来有点像
a cop-out it seems like you're just jamming together some sorry yes yes no it absolutely you're absolutely right right because um that's that's precisely what it precisely what it is but also um your answer is kind of the same as mine it's real similar yeah what i don't i don't know what either of those two things are. Somebody explain. Can I infer that zip fold is transform reduce? Or could it be alternatively? With multiple. Okay, but transform reduce is just reduce.
是在敷衍，感觉你只是把一些——抱歉，对，对，不，完全是，你完全说得对，对，因为……嗯，那……那恰恰就是它，恰恰就是它是什么，但同时……嗯，你的答案跟我有点像，非常相似，对。我不知道这两者是什么。谁来解释一下。我能否推断出zip fold就是transform reduce？或者也可以是别的？带有多个。好吧，但transform reduce其实就是reduce。
Okay. So hang on a second. We know what a fold is, right? We have some accumulator, and as you iterate over the sequence you update this accumulator and you have some function that returns this new value, fold or reduce or standard accumulate. And then we can have a short circuiting version of this that is fold while. Right, And in that case, your,
好吧。等一下。我们知道fold是什么，对吧？我们有一些累加器，当你在序列上迭代时，你更新这个累加器，并且你有一些函数返回这个新值，fold或者reduce，或者标准的accumulate。然后我们可以有一个短路版本的fold，也就是fold while。对，在这种情况下，你的……
your function returns two pieces of information. It returns your updated accumulator and it returns like whether to continue or not. So that might be a pair or you can return an optional, however you do it, or you can use an out parameter, but it has to return these two pieces of information. Right.
你的函数返回两部分信息。它返回你更新后的累加器，并返回是否继续。所以那可以是一个pair，或者你可以返回一个optional，无论你如何实现，或者你可以使用输出参数，但它必须返回这两部分信息。对。
Yeah. So that's like a fold while it It's a short-circuiting or a version of fold that can short-circuit. It doesn't have to. And then you can do, yes, a sort of cop-out version that can take multiple sequences at one time and have an NRE predicate. And then you can say, you can argue that that is more general because you can have it, you know, specialize it for the unary case as well. Right.
对。所以这就像是一个fold while，它是fold的一个可以短路的版本。它不一定非得短路。然后你可以做，是的，一个可以同时接受多个序列并带有N元谓词的敷衍版本。然后你可以说，你可以辩称这更通用，因为你也可以为一元的情况将其专门化。对。
So that is my, the root of all algorithms because the zip version you can use to implement things like mismatch and equal and adjacent find and probably others, but those are the ones that come to mind. See, I think we all just answered the same way. Yeah, I was going to say reduce, but like some of you just said a fancier reduce than. Yeah.
所以这是我的，所有算法的根源，因为zip版本你可以用来实现诸如mismatch、equal、adjacent_find以及可能的其他算法，但这些是我能想到的。你看，我觉得我们大家的回答其实都一样。对，我本来想说reduce，但你们有些人说了一个更花哨的reduce……
You asked what was the most basic, the version of it from which everything else can be. Right, but we didn't ask for the most generic. We asked for the most basic and the the the version of it from which everything else can be right but we asked we didn't ask for the most generic we asked for the most basic and the answer is reduce no i mean i think there are some subtle well ben you're gonna say something now um i was gonna say i i i think ultimately this question is sort of ill-formed it's interesting to think about but it's not useful every day um and i and i think one of the points of algorithms is to be multitudinous and have lots of different formulations so
你问哪个是最基础的，也就是其他一切都可以从中……对，但我们没有问哪个最通用。我们问的是哪个最基础，并且……版本，其他一切都可以从中……对，但我们问的不是最通用，我们问的是最基础，答案是reduce。不，我的意思是，我觉得有一些微妙的……好吧，本，你现在要说点什么了……我本来想说，我……我最终认为这个问题本身就有些问题，思考它很有趣，但日常并不实用……而且我认为算法的特点之一就是具有多样性，有许多不同的表述方式，所以
you know trying to implement all the algorithms in terms of one is is interesting as a pedagogical exercise but not much more um and i do think we've said basically all the same algorithm in my case I said scan while I implemented scan while once as a one function interface to a map as a one, sorry say that again as the one function, pretty much the one function interface to a map a map being like a C++ stud map? yeah, something with that interface um so something you can iterate actually think of an ordered map right so um something you can
你知道，试图用一个算法来实现所有算法，作为教学练习很有趣，但仅此而已……而且我的确认为，基本上我们说的都是同一种算法，在我的情况下，我说了scan while，我曾把scan while实现为对map的单函数接口，作为一个，抱歉，再说一遍，作为单函数，几乎是对map的单函数接口，这里的map就像是C++的std::map？对，具有那种接口的东西……所以你可以迭代，实际上可以认为是一个有序map，对吧……所以你可以
iterate and you can take you can take as long as you as long as you like and when you're you know it's a it's scanned while so it takes interestingly tristan said like i don't know how you formulate it tristan but in my case i formulated it with a separate predicate you seem to suggest that the the one function returned both the the fold the folded value and the and whether or not to continue um That was my sort of, yeah, my way of doing it would be, so you pass it one function that returns you the two pieces of information. Various ways you could return that information, but I guess you could do it with having two separate,
迭代，只要你愿意，你可以持续任意长时间，当你知道的时候……它是scan while，所以它有趣地……特里斯坦说，我不知道你是怎么表述的，特里斯坦，但在我的情况下，我是用一个单独的谓词来表述的，你似乎暗示那个单一函数既返回了fold之后的值，也返回了是否继续……那是我的一种，是的，我的做法是，你传给它一个函数，它返回给你这两部分信息。你可以用各种方式返回这些信息，但我想你可以通过使用两个独立的、
perhaps it's more general to have two separate functions, one of which does the accumulation and one of which decides whether to continue or not well i yeah i mean i think they're equivalent it's just a case of in my case it seemed obvious to to put the predicate separate in the api um so i did but yes it it it goes down the sequence. It does a scan. It stops when you want it to stop. And that could be that you can have a predicate that works on the accumulated value, or you can have a predicate that works on the sort of depth index you've scanned to. Right. Okay. works on the sort of depth index you've scanned to right okay and what's interesting about if we
也许拥有两个独立的函数更通用，一个负责累加，另一个决定是否继续。嗯，我，我的意思是，我觉得它们是等价的，这只是个情况，在我的情况下，在API中把谓词分开似乎是显而易见的，所以我这么做了……但是的，它遍历序列。它进行扫描。当你想让它停的时候它就停。这可以是你有一个针对累加值工作的谓词，或者你有一个针对你扫描到的深度索引工作的谓词。对。好的。针对你扫描到的深度索引工作的谓词，对，好的。而且有趣的是，如果我们
ignore the zip part of the zip fold while and we just compare fold while versus scan while is kind of what you're talking about ben is that it's not really useful to think about implement like you can you can implement every algorithm in terms of those two but there's trade-offs for each one right the scan while you're going to always be building up a linear amount of, you know, space depending on what you're doing. And then if you're trying to implement a reduction in terms of that scan, that's kind of wasteful because you don't need to materialize all the first, you know, zero to N minus one values. You really only want the last one. Whereas with a fold, you can implement folds obviously directly, which is avoids the problem with implementing a fold in terms of a scan while, but then if you want to implement a scan in terms of a fold, depending on
忽略zip fold while中的zip部分，只把fold while和scan while进行比较，这正是你刚才所说的，本，觉得去考虑实现……就像你可以用那两个来实现任何算法，但每一个都有权衡，对吧？对于scan while，根据你在做什么，你总是会构建一定线性的空间。然后，如果你试图用那个scan来实现一个reduction，那就有点浪费了，因为你不需要把所有前0到N-1个值都实体化。你真的只需要最后一个。而对于fold，你可以直接实现fold，这显然避免了用scan while来实现fold的问题，但如果你想用fold来实现scan，取决于
the copying semantics of your accumulator from iteration to iteration. Like I remember in one of your talks, Ben, you actually talked about how the, you know, they changed some requirements in C++ 17 or 20 which made it possible to avoid those copies. So if you were building up like a string by doing concatenation, you could actually do it non-suboptimally. So I think you could do it optimally in certain cases.
你的累加器从一次迭代到下一次迭代的拷贝语义。就像我记得在你的某个演讲中，本，你实际上谈到了他们如何在C++17或20中改变了一些要求，使得避免这些拷贝成为可能。所以如果你通过拼接来构建一个string，你实际上可以做到非次优。所以我觉得你在某些情况下可以做到最优。
In 20, accumulate was changed to move the accumulated value through the computation. Right. And that's probably what you think of. So then you avoid those copies. I mean, accumulating strings still incurs temporaries and allocation and that sort of thing. But it's just that now they get moved instead of copied so it's slightly better i still wouldn't recommend that use case yeah so you know you can implement a scan in terms of a fold and a fold in
在C++20中，accumulate被修改为在计算过程中移动累加值。对，那可能就是你想到的。所以这样你就避免了那些拷贝。我的意思是，累加字符串仍然会产生临时对象、分配和诸如此类的事情。但这只是意味着现在它们是被移动而不是被拷贝，所以稍微好一点了。我仍然不推荐那种用例。是的，所以你可以用fold来实现scan，也可以用scan在……
terms of a scan but there's trade-offs in each one which is why you would probably argue you don't want to do those the same way like definitely in in Thrust, we do not implement our reduce or our scan in terms of one or the other. They are two fundamental algorithms. Correct, Bryce? Yeah. I mean, I think that the fundamental difference is the shape of the output right and so there will always be an
用scan来实现fold，但它们各自都有权衡，这就是为什么你可能会辩称你不想用同一种方式来做这些事——绝对的，在Thrust中，我们并不是用其中一个来实现reduce或scan。它们是两个基本的算法。对吗，布莱斯？是的。我的意思是，我认为根本的区别在于输出的形状，对吧，所以用一种来实现另一种总是会存在
inefficiency in doing one in terms of the other yeah that reduce gives you back a single thing you know a single final value where is a scan gives you back n things so if you implement the reduction in terms
低效。是的，reduce给你返回单个东西，你知道的，一个单一的最终结果，而scan给你返回n个东西。所以如果你用scan来实现reduction，
of the scan, then you will have computed or stored or kept around more information than you needed. You only needed the last value of that scanned array, but you had to build up and keep that whole thing around. So it may be storage inefficient, it may be compute inefficient. On the other hand, if you implement the scan in terms of the reduction, then you have to build up your output array sort of on the fly, and that's going to potentially be inefficient you can't just allocate it all uh a priori so the big question is the two nvidia employees don't have a suffix underscore while so bryce i'll ask you how do you you know the the critic would say you can't implement short
那么你将计算、存储或保留比你需要更多的信息。你只需要那个被扫描数组的最后一个值，但你却不得不构建并保留整个东西。所以它可能在存储上低效，在计算上低效。另一方面，如果你用reduction来实现scan，那么你必须在运行过程中构建你的输出数组，这可能会变得低效，你不能只是先验地把它们全部分配好……所以最大的问题是，这两个NVIDIA的员工都没有下划线_while后缀，所以布莱斯，我要问你，你知道的，批评者会说你不能实现短……
short short circuiting algorithms so how algorithms. So how is reduced possibly? Because I think... Yeah, but see, I'm thinking about in terms of parallel primitives. And in parallel, if I'm doing something like a find if, it's just more efficient. Or it's less efficient, but faster.
短……短路算法。所以reduce怎么可能是……因为我认为……对，但你看，我是从并行原语的角度来考虑的。而在并行中，如果我做类似find_if之类的事情，它只是更高效。或者它效率较低，但速度更快。
Something we've talked about before to simply not short circuit yeah that's the same thing i would say but if david olsen was here because i've said this before in a meeting david is a fellow nvidia that works on on mvc plus plus yeah and he works on compiler stuff as well uh He heard me say that and was like, well, that's an oversimplification. He says, it depends. And actually, didn't we get a request to talk about, I can't remember the name of the algorithm implementation where you do successively. So like if you're trying to do something like a find if or a short circuiting algorithm,
我们以前讨论过的一点是，简单地不短路。是的，我也这么说。但如果大卫·奥尔森在这里——因为我以前在会议上说过这个，大卫是NVIDIA的一位研究员，从事C++方面的工作——对，他也从事编译器方面的工作……他听到我这么说时，就说，嗯，那是一种过度简化。他说，这得看情况。事实上，我们难道没有收到过一个请求，要求谈谈——我不记得那个算法实现的名称了——在那里你连续地进行。所以如果你试图做类似find_if或短路算法的事情，
the way to do it, an implementation on gpu or something in parallel is to just choose different values of n and so you do like a full-blown reduction but only on the first 10 and then if you don't find if you don't end up short circuiting in that first 10 then you try the next 20 or something i can't remember if you start from the 10 mark to the the 20% mark. For a sufficiently large dataset, it may be correct that short-circuiting is going to be faster on modern parallel hardware. you know, search in like some, some text and it's like, you know, gigabytes upon gigabytes of data, and I'm going to be loading that onto and off of the GPU or whatever my parallel processor is. Um, then yeah, like short circuiting might matter if I'm like searching for something in like a hundred or like a 200 gigabyte, you know, input. Um, I just, I don't think that's the common case. And it definitely slows down the common case having to do short circuiting in a parallel computation, because that means
实现它的方法，在GPU上或并行环境中，就是选择不同的n值，所以你进行全面彻底的reduction，但只在前10个元素上进行，如果你没有找到——如果你在前10个元素中没有触发短路，那么你尝试接下来的20个或类似的东西。我不记得你是不是从第10个标记开始，到20%的标记。对于足够大的数据集，短路在现代并行硬件上会更快，这可能是对的。你知道，在一些文本中搜索，比如有数GB甚至数TB的数据，我要把它加载到GPU或任何我的并行处理器上，然后又卸载下来。那么，是的，如果我在搜索诸如100GB或200GB的输入中的某些东西时，短路可能会很重要。我只是觉得这不是常见情况。在并行计算中进行短路肯定会拖慢常见情况，因为这意味着
you're doing some sort of, either some sort of branching or some sort of work dispatch logic where you're not actually queuing up all the work at once because you're going to launch some of it and then wait. And like, that's one of the problems with what you just described is like, if you do, oh, I'm going to do some of this computation and then see if I got an answer and then launch more. Then if you're on a system where your work and queue times have a long latency, which tends to be true about GPUs, GPUs are bandwidth optimized, not latency optimized, you pay a penalty for not enqueuing your work as early as possible. And it's not just the penalty of how long it takes to send the work to the GPU. That's actually come down a lot in recent years. It's just the fact that that first chunk of work may happen so quickly. And then whatever logic you're doing on your CPU, you know, those are cycles where you're not using your compute heavy resource resource. Like, there's not really much point in having, you know,
你正在做某种形式的分支，或者是某种工作调度逻辑，在那里你实际上并没有一次性将所有工作排入队列，因为你将启动一部分工作然后等待。就像，你刚刚描述的问题之一是，如果你这样做——哦，我要做一部分这个计算，然后看看我是否得到了一个答案，然后启动更多。那么，如果你在一个系统上，你的工作和队列时间的延迟很长，这往往是GPU的真实写照——GPU是带宽优化型的，而不是延迟优化型的——你就会为没有尽早将工作排入队列而付出代价。这不仅是将工作发送到GPU所需时间的代价。近年来，这实际上已经大幅下降了。这只是因为那第一块工作可能发生得太快了。然后你在CPU上做的任何逻辑——你知道，那些都是你没有使用计算密集型资源的周期。如果你不能一直利用它，拥有……
the world's most powerful processor in your system if you're not utilizing it all the time. And so I do think that sort of speculatively computing is the way to go. You know, maybe the best way to do it would not be to launch a piece and then wait to see whether you get a response, but instead just put the work up into multiple chunks and enqueue them all at once and then to cancel later if you find the result. And that may be a better approach because then you don't have to necessarily have the work
世界上最强大的处理器在你的系统中其实并没有太大意义。所以我的确认为某种猜测性计算才是正确的方向。你知道，最好的方法可能不是启动一部分然后等待看是否有响应，而是把工作分成多个块，把它们一次性全部排入队列，如果后来发现结果再取消。这可能是更好的方法，因为这样你不一定非要让工作
like check for completion or anything. It's like you just, you have like this cancellation case um but uh i don't even know how one would structure that on um on our platform um you know whether whether there's no graceful way to cancel some out some outstanding submitted work that does not require the work to um have built-in support for cancellation. I think it's important to say also that, so yes, so all of that kind of strategy of parallelism and whether or not to actually short circuit, I think is important. But in some sense, it's an engineering choice.
去检查完成情况什么的。就像你只是——你有这样的取消情况，但是……我甚至不知道如何在我们的平台上构建它……你知道，是否存在某种优雅的方式来取消某些悬而未决的已提交工作，而不需要这些工作本身具备对取消的内置支持。我认为同样重要的是要说，是的，所有这些并行策略以及实际上是否要进行短路，我认为这很重要。但在某种意义上，这是一种工程选择。
And the formulation of the function scan while or fold while that's an ergonomic choice right that's that's the user wants to use this function because that's the way they think about it and that's that's the eventual result they want to get out right and if they can do it in one function you know otherwise it would be you know having to deal with scan and then i don't know what i find and maybe something else so i think there is hopefully we can have our cake and eat it and have the ergonomic function that uh but but yes obviously don't it is frequently faster to do the work rather than as as bryce just said stop branch re-enqueue whatever in in the parallel context in the parallel case yeah if you're sequential it's always well is it always i think it's always it's always faster
而函数 scan while 或 fold while 的 formulation，这是一种符合人体工程学的选择，对吧？这就是用户想要使用这个函数的原因，因为这就是他们思考问题的方式，也是他们想要得到的最终结果。如果他们能用一个函数搞定……否则你就得处理 scan，然后我不知道，还得找点别的什么或者别的。所以我觉得，希望我们能鱼与熊掌兼得，既有符合人体工程学的函数……但是，是的，很显然，做实际工作通常比（正如 Bryce 刚刚所说）在并行上下文中停止、分支、重新入队等等要快。在并行情况下，是的，如果你是串行的，那总是……等一下，真的是总是吗？我觉得总是，总是更快。
to just stop right if you're going left to right or right to left. Well, it depends. A branch-every loop might not be faster. It depends on what you mean by serial. If you mean single-threaded, no, it may not be faster because a vectorized version of the algorithm may be faster. Is vectorized fall under the category of serial, though? But that's why I said single threaded you may have a single thread like that's what I think a lot of people would think of as serial
直接停下来，对吧？如果你是从左到右，或者从右到左。嗯，这得看情况。带有每个循环分支的版本可能并不更快。这取决于你所说的“串行”是什么意思。如果你指的是单线程，不，它不一定更快，因为算法的矢量化版本可能会更快。不过，矢量化属于串行的范畴吗？但这就是为什么我说单线程，你可能只有一个单线程，就像我觉很多人会认为的那样是串行的。
and by that I mean sequential a better term then does sequential definitely rule out vectorization yeah but nobody actually writes code like that I mean even if you writes code like that. I mean, even if you write code like that today, every... I was going to say, like, people write code like that, but that's just what your compiler... Every modern major processor,
我指的是顺序执行，那么“顺序”这个词是不是就绝对排除了矢量化？是的，但实际上没有人会写那种代码。我的意思是，即使你写了那样的代码……我是说，即使你今天写那样的代码，每一个……我本来想说，人们会写那样的代码，但那只是你的编译器……每一个现代主流处理器，
you're not getting performance out of it if you're not vectorizing your code. And so you're leaving a huge chunk of performance on the table if your code isn't being vectorized. And so if you're calling something like a reduction or a find if on any modern processor, and by modern I mean like last 20 years, not really even modern anymore. Well, any desktop or server processor. I mean, the target, my my target doesn't doesn't do
如果你不对代码进行矢量化，你就无法从中获得性能。所以如果你的代码没有被矢量化，你就在桌面上留下了很大一部分性能。因此，如果你在任何现代处理器上调用类似于 reduction 或 find if 之类的东西，我说的现代是指过去 20 年的，其实已经不算很现代了。嗯，任何桌面或服务器处理器。我的意思是，目标，我的目标根本不进行那种矢量化。嗯，确实，但是我们大多数人都是在桌面、服务器或移动处理器上编程，所有这些本质上都是并行计算机。我的意思是，很显然，你知道，在超过某个问题规模之后，是的，短路会更快。但我觉得在常见情况下，问题规模……这可能不一定，就像整个问题一样：你是否应该使用像 std map 那样基于红黑树的数据结构，还是只想用一个基本上就是个花哨的 vector 的 flat map？在很多情况下，你只是想要 flat map，你想要……“机器同理心”就是 Matt 使用的术语。是的，Bjorn Faller 有个很棒的演讲，我会找到它，我不记得它的标题了。
vectorization like that at all yeah yeah yeah sure but but the majority the majority of us are programming on uh on a desktop server or mobile processor all of which are fundamentally parallel uh computers i mean i mean obviously if you know above a certain uh a certain problem size yeah short circuiting is going to be faster but i think in in the in the common case problem size and it may it may not be this is like the whole like should you use like a you know or like a stood map like a red black trees type data structure or do you just want like a flat map that's just like basically a fancy vector um in a lot of cases you just want the flat map you want the uh machine sympathy is the the term that matt uses yeah there's a great talk by bjorn faller um i'll find it i can't remember the title
这大概叫缓存友好性或者名字里有类似的东西，他做过好几次这个演讲。我有一会儿以为你说的缓存是指钱（cash），然后我在想：什么？是缓存（cache）！然后我觉得，他一开始只是发现了一些性能问题，然后最终有点像……我甚至不一定会称之为刮牦牛毛（yak shaving），但他最终陷入了一个兔子洞，最终结果……好吧，我有点剧透了这个演讲，但他最终重新实现了一堆东西，然后发现他做的事情叫做 B 树（B-tree），这基本上就是一种修改后的树类型，具有好得多的缓存局部性。所以它最终比他们一直在使用的那种理论上不同的数据结构性能高得多。
of it it's i think it's called cash friendliness or something in the title he's given it a couple times where i thought for a moment i thought you meant cash like money and i was like what c-a-c-h-e uh and he i think it starts off by just like he finds some performance problem and then he ends up kind of like i wouldn't necessarily call it yak shaving but he ends up going down a rabbit hole where he ends up ultimately well i kind of ruined the talk but he ends up you know re-implementing a bunch of stuff and then discovering that what he did was something called a bee tree that was just basically like a modified type of tree that had like way better cache locality. And so it ended up being way more performant than like this theoretical different type of data structure that they were using.
我发现这超级有趣。而且他用的工具，我不记得是 Valgrind 还是 Grind，或者是怎么发音的。但他展示了所有的缓存未命中（cache miss）之类的事情，就像……当然，他们教给你这种理论上的大 O 符号性能之类的内容，但归根结底，你实际上是在硬件上运行东西，那里的情况大不相同。这很有趣，因为如果我没记错的话，B 树是为存储发明的，对吧？它们进行了优化，因为在连续层之间（访问数据结构的连续层）存在巨大的延迟差异。我想是的，特别是因为最后一层可能在旋转磁盘上。所以这很有趣，
And I found that super interesting. And he did it all with, I can't remember if it was Valgrind or Grind or however you pronounce that. But he showed like all the cache misses and whatnot and that like uh sure they teach you this theoretical like you know big o notation performance stuff but at the end of the day you're actually running stuff on hardware where it's a much different story that's interesting because if i'm not mistaken b trees were invented for for storage right they're optimized where there's a the big latency difference between you know between between successive layers accessing successive layers of the data structure i guess so in particular you know like that last layer could be on a spinning disk. Yeah. So it's interesting, you know,
现代架构中多层的缓存和内存使得 B 树……这种差距……是的，这种差距。主存延迟和缓存延迟之间的差距在近年有所增加。
the multiple-layered cache and memory that we have in modern architectures makes B-trees... The spread between... Yeah, the spread. The spread between mean memory latency and cache latency has increased in recent years.
并且随着处理器变得越来越快，你也变得更加容易注意到这种差距和延迟。基本上，随着计算在近年来变得如此便宜，它已经
And also as processors have gotten faster that you've become a lot more susceptible to notice that spread and latency basically as compute has come compute has become so cheap in recent years that it's
变得基本上是免费的，你知道的。当每个处理器都能……也许对你来说，Bryce，当每个 CPU 或 GPU 能够完全利用各种资源时，你需要能够提供足够的数据。因此现在有一个非常狭窄的窗口，关于你需要移动多少数据才能真正完全利用你的中央处理器。我还是说中央处理器吧。所以在光谱的另一端，
essentially free you know when every processor can do maybe for you Bryce when when every when every uh CPU or GPU able to like fully utilize things uh you need to be able to feed enough data and sort of the this there's now this very narrow window for um how much data you need to move um to actually be able to fully utilize your central processor. I'll say central processor then. So on the other end of the spectrum,
我想对 C++ Now 上的演讲做一个补充。我的朋友兼同事 Luke Valenti 做了一个关于微型嵌入式系统上的组合（composition）的演讲。为了让你对“微型”有个概念，他在进行现场编程，实际上是在面包板上构建。他用一个拥有 1KB 程序内存和 64 字节 RAM 的微型微处理器驱动一个 LED，使用的是 C++20。那个演讲太棒了。那个演讲之所以棒，有几个原因：第一，仅仅是看到你可以在这种系统上使用
I would like to add an addendum to the talks at C++ Now. My friend and colleague Luke Valenti gave a talk about composition on tiny embedded systems. And just to give you an idea of what was meant by Tiny, he was live coding and indeed building on a breadboard. He was driving an LED with a Tiny microprocessor with 1K of program memory and 64 bytes of ram in c++ 20 and that talk was that talk was awesome that talk was awesome for a couple of reasons one just just to see that you can use
C++20；第二，观众们都提心吊胆，因为这确实非常考验 Luke 是不是能把接线也搞对。有很多事情可能会出错，但最后都成功了，太精彩了。我记得 Jason Turner 在 CppCon 上用 Commodore 64 做过演讲。但是，是的，他这次用的 RAM 少了整整一千倍，而且还在使用 C++20，这太惊人了。我确实认为我们在高端处理器中看到的趋势对所有处理器总体上都有长尾效应。你可能在小型 DSP 或小型嵌入式处理器上面临更多的计算受限，但你受计算限制的程度已经不如从前了。
c++ 20 on that kind of system two the audience were on the edge of their seats because it was really you know very sensitive to luke to Luke actually getting the wiring correct as well. Lots of things that could go wrong, but it all came off and it was brilliant. I remember Jason Turner's talk, CppCon one with the Commodore 64. But yeah, he's gone and done it with a thousand times less RAM. He's still using C++ 20 is amazing i do think that the trends that we see in the high end of processors do have a long tail effect on all processors in general like you may be more compute constrained on a um you know a small dsp or a small embedded processor but you're less compute constrained than you used to
真正改变的是计算与内存延迟和吞吐量的比例。就像计算延迟和吞吐量一样，计算延迟下降的速度比内存延迟快，计算吞吐量的上升速度也比内存吞吐量快。这就缩小了你为了完全利用资源而每移动一字节内存需要执行多少计算操作的窗口。所以，你知道，也许在我们历史的早期，我们花在等待计算上的时间更多。但如今，大多数处理器都在等待内存被移动到某处。所以问题是，我们该把这个算法叫什么？我们把这一个算法叫什么？是的，这是什么？扫描（scan）和折叠（fold）有没有一个统称？叫 scaffold（脚手架）？
be. And what's really changed has been the ratio of compute to memory latency and throughput. Like compute latency and throughput, compute latency has gone down quicker than memory latency and compute throughput has risen quicker than memory throughput. And that has narrowed the window of how many compute operations you need to do per byte of memory that you move to fully utilize things. And so that, you know, maybe, maybe at earlier points in our history, we were spending more time waiting for compute. But these days, most processors are waiting for waiting for memory to be moved somewhere. So the question is, what do we call this algorithm? What do we call this one algorithm? Yeah, what is this? Is there an umbrella term for scans and folds scaffold
天哪，现在我们有了 scan duction（扫描归约），还有 scaffold。Scaffold while，我喜欢这个。我的意思是，我无论如何都会把它们归入不同的类别，因为 scan 给你的结果类似于一种懒惰的、类似于范围适配器（range adapter）的东西，对吧？当你请求适配范围的每个元素时，它会去获取前一个元素，所以对我来说，它几乎是一个独立的类别。这些范围适配器与 eager（急切求值）算法（如 Fold，或者其他上百种会遍历整个范围并给你返回某种结果的算法）属于不同的类别。
oh man we've now we've got scan duction and we've got scaffold a scaffold while i like that i mean i sort of put them in different categories anyway because as a scan gives you back like it's a sort of lazy uh like a range adapter right like as you ask for each element of the adaptive range it goes and it fetches the previous element and so that's it's almost a separate category to me anyway. These range adapters are a different category from the eager algorithms like Fold or the hundred or so other ones
它们有点……我觉得，我不同意。我认为你这是从某种特定的实现策略或技术的角度来描述的。而且我认为你完全可以像那样懒惰地实现一个 fold。而你刚才描述的那种实现 scan 的懒惰方式在某些平台和某些架构上会效率极其低下。
that will iterate over the whole range and give you back some result. They're sort of- I think, I disagree. I think that you're describing this from the perspective of one particular implementation strategy or technique. And I think that you could implement a fold lazily just like that. And the lazy way that you're describing implementing a scan would be horribly inefficient
特别是，如果你在并行执行 scan，你就无法做到那种懒惰的做法。所以我认为它们都可以被懒惰地或急切地表达出来。而且我确实认为它们属于同一类事物。我从来没尝试过做并行 scan，所以我不知道。哦，好吧，我们已经有一整集节目了。
on certain platforms and in certain architectures. In particular, if you're doing the scan in parallel, you can't do that lazy thing. So I think that both of them can be expressed either lazily or eagerly. And I do think that they're the same family of things. I haven't ever tried to do a parallel scan, so I don't know. Oh, well, we have a whole episode already.
对，我记得听过。但如果你在脑海中思考 scan 和 reduction 的计算模式……我能不能不在脑海里思考？这是一个播客，你的脑海必须是这个概念去的地方。但是如果你思考它，它的形态是相同的……它本质上是相同的形态，这只是一个关于你从其中得到什么结果的问题……我不知道，我同意……所以我在尝试
Yeah, I remember listening to it. But if you think about in your head the compute pattern for a scan and a reduction. Can I think about it not in my head? This is a podcast, and your head is going to have to be where this goes. But if you think about it it it is the same shape um uh you it is fundamentally the same shape it's just it's just a question of like what are the results that you're getting out of it um i don't know i i agree like so i was i was trying to
搜索，因为我以为在 Thrust 文档的某个地方，他们在 Thrust 头文件中把算法归类了。什么文档？是的，非常搞笑。Thrust.github.io slash doc，链接在描述里。我以为它在某个地方把 scan 放在了……所以在算法下面，有搜索、复制、归约、重排、前缀和（prefix sums）以及转换。所以我不确定前缀和是不是新的，但我以为我曾经在 reductions 标题下看到过 scan，这总是让我很烦恼。我有一张基本类别的表格，里面有 map，有 folds
search because i thought at one point on the Thrust documentation, they bucket the algorithms in the Thrust header. What documentation? Yeah, very funny. Thrust.github.io slash doc and link in the description. And I thought at one point it had the scans under the – so like the – under algorithms, there's searching, copying, reductions, reordering, prefix sums, and transformation. So I'm not sure if prefix sums is new, but I thought at one point I saw the scans under the reductions header, which always bothered me. And I have this like one table of fundamental categories and there's maps, there's folds
或 reduces。然后我在某个地方把 scan 放进去了，但 scan 介于 map 和 reduce/reductions 之间。它们的相似之处在于它们像 map 一样给你返回 n 个值（或者正负一），而它们又像 reduce 一样带有状态，而 map 没有。所以它们就像是带有状态的 map。不过我不知道，我从来没拿定主意。不过我确实觉得它们是不同的，但是……
or reduces. And then at one point I like kind of put scans but like scans are in between like maps and reduce uh reductions like they're like maps and that they give you n values back or you know plus or minus one and they're like reductions and that they carry state whereas maps don't so they're like they're like a map that carries state but i don't know i've never made my mind up like i do feel that they're different though uh But also kind of now that we have this FoldWile versus ScanWile, it'd be nice if, like, I don't want to call it a stateful algorithm underscore while. I was just going to say you could use scan to implement a map.
而且现在我们有了 FoldWhile 相比 ScanWhile，如果能不用把带状态的算法叫 underscore while 就会更好了。我本来正要说你可以用 scan 来实现一个 map。
You could look at a map as a special case of a scan. Anyway, gosh. Yes, definitely. look at a map as a special case of a scan anyway yes yeah definitely i was gonna say i mean i think i think we're overly aggrandizing this with the one algorithm to rule them all because it it's not even one algorithm to rule most you're ruining my clickbait ben we're very much thinking in the model of like, okay, these are algorithms that work on a single sequence, a linear sequence, a one-dimensional sequence. And we're talking about reducing or, you know, all the things that encompasses within that frame. But, you know, we're not talking about unfolds.
你可以把 map 看作是 scan 的一个特例。不管怎样，天哪。是的，绝对的。把 map 看作是 scan 的一个特例，不管怎样，是的，绝对的。我本来想说，我觉得我们用“统治一切的单一算法”来夸大其词了，因为这甚至不是“统治大部分的单一算法”。你在毁掉我的点击标题党，Ben。我们的思维模式很大程度上局限于：好吧，这些是在单个序列、线性序列、一维序列上运行的算法。我们在讨论 reduction，或者在这个框架内包含的所有内容。但是，我们没有在讨论 unfold（展开）。
Folds and unfolds. Folds and unfolds can be viewed as different sides of the same coin and implemented in terms of each other. And we're not talking about graph algorithms, which is a whole, you know, we're talking about one-dimensional algorithms in a sense. Or possibly fixed-dimensional algorithms. We're not talking about... But you can build a lot of the other stuff on top of reductions what is an unfold an unfold is um the simplest example of an unfold that we have in c++ is probably iota so rather than going from a sequence and producing a value you're going the other way around you're going from a seed value and you're unfolding it into a sequence.
Fold 和 unfold。Fold 和 unfold 可以被视为同一枚硬币的两面，并且可以相互实现。我们也没有在讨论图算法，这完全是……你知道的，我们在某种意义上讨论的是一维算法。或者可能是固定维度的算法。我们没有在讨论……但你可以在 reduction 的基础之上构建许多其他东西。什么是 unfold？我们在 C++ 中拥有的最简单的 unfold 例子可能就是 iota。所以，与其从一个序列出发产生一个值，你反其道而行之，你从一个种子值（seed value）出发，将其展开为一个序列。
The unfold in Haskell is called iterate, right? Iterate is one of the, yeah, a general form of unfold. So iterate takes a seed value and a function and it gives you back the sequence of X and then F of X and f of f of x etc yeah that makes sense and iota is is that same shape just where the function is the increment function i was just thinking about how would you express scans and reductions mathematically. And I think mathematically you would define both in terms of summation would be the underlying operation. There's a reason it's called prefix sum. So I do think that they're both of the family of summation algorithms.
Haskell 中的 unfold 叫做 iterate，对吧？Iterate 是 unfold 的通用形式之一。所以 iterate 接收一个种子值和一个函数，然后给你返回一个由 X、F(X)、F(F(X)) 等构成的序列。是的，这说得通。而 iota 就是这种相同的形态，只不过其中的函数是递增函数。我刚才在想，你该如何在数学上表达 scan 和 reduction。我想在数学上你会用求和（summation）来定义这两者作为底层操作。它被称为前缀和是有原因的。所以我确实认为它们都属于求和算法家族。
Sorry, I was just going to say, does that mean that something like a split or a group by or something like that, where you go from a sequence of T to a sequence of sequences of T, is that also a kind of unfold operation? Or is that a different category? I mean, in a sense, it could be, I guess. I would say yes. I wasn't familiar with the term unfold. So I'm just trying to get it straight in my head yeah it is used
抱歉，我刚才只是想说，这是否意味着像 split（分割）或 group by（分组）之类的事情——你从一个 T 的序列变成一个 T 的序列的序列——这也是一种 unfold 操作？还是说这是个不同的类别？我的意思是，从某种意义上说，可能是吧。我会说是的。我对 unfold 这个术语不太熟悉。所以我只是想在脑海里把它理清楚。是的，它被用于
it's more normally used to go from a you know talking about the one dimensional case to go from a seed to to a sequence but yes I mean so reduce is called reduce because it reduces the number of dimensions by one, right, in the data. And if we think about the reverse of that as an unfold, then if you're increasing the number of dimensions by one,
它通常更多地用于从一个……（说到一维情况）从一个种子走向一个序列。但是的，我的意思是，reduce 之所以叫 reduce，是因为它在数据中把维度的数量减少了一1，对吧？如果我们把这的反向操作视为 unfold，那么如果你把维度的数量增加 1，
then as well as going from zero dimensions to one dimension, you could also go from one dimension to two dimensions, I suppose. Okay. But it's super useful for things like, oh, I saw a talk at LambdaConf back in the day about tournament design. You're designing a tournament for some game or sport, and you can express that algorithmically with a sort of unfold. Don't ask me the details because I've forgotten it, but go find the talk. Link in the description, yeah. I remember at the time.
除了从零维走向一维之外，我想你也可以从一维走向二维。好的。但这对于某些事情超级有用，比如——我以前在 LambdaConf 上看过一个关于锦标赛设计的演讲。你为某种游戏或运动设计锦标赛，你可以用某种 unfold 在算法上表达这一点。不要问我细节，因为我已经忘了，但去找出那个演讲吧。链接在描述里，是的。我当时记得。
We'll find that talk. Understanding it, but, you know, lack of use has meant that it's gone out of my brain. The thing I was going to say about unfolds is that for a long time in my talks i used to refer to i used to mention that reductions are known as catamorphisms in category theory and that unfolds or folds are known as catamorphisms and unfolds are known as anamorphisms and for a while i used to refer to all of these splitting algorithms like chunk, chump by, adjacent, slide, et cetera, the range adapters that we got in C++23, and these all already exist in languages like Haskell, et cetera.
我们会找到那个演讲的。理解它，但是，由于缺乏使用，它已经从我的脑海中淡出了。关于 unfold，我想说的是，在我的演讲中，我有一段时间经常提到——我曾提到在范畴论（category theory）中 reduction 被称为 catamorphisms（终代数同态），而 unfold 或 fold 被称为 catamorphisms，unfold 被称为 anamorphisms（始代数同态）。有一段时间，我把所有这些拆分算法（如 chunk、chunk by、adjacent、slide 等等，我们在 C++23 中获得的范围适配器，这些在 Haskell 等语言中已经存在了）
I used to refer to those as anamorphisms, which technically they are, but anamorphisms, a.k.a. unfolds, are a larger umbrella term that I did not mean to use. I meant purely the ones that are going from a sequence of values to like a sequence of sequences. I did not mean like iota and iterate. And I don't even really think about two-dimensional ones to like three-dimensional ones. I was purely talking about, you know, you have a sequence of values and you want to chunk adjacent equal ones. And so I've started referring to those as just like splits in the J language.
我曾经把它们称为 anamorphisms，从技术上讲它们确实是，但我使用 anamorphisms（又名 unfold）时用了一个更大的统称，而我本意并非如此。我纯粹指的是那些从一个值的序列走向类似于序列的序列的算法。我不是指像 iota 和 iterate 那样。而且我甚至不怎么考虑从二维到三维的情况。我纯粹是在谈论，你知道，你有一个值的序列，然后你想把相邻相等的元素分块（chunk）。所以我开始把它们简称为 J 语言中的 splits。
That category of algorithms is known as cut, which I've maybe is growing on me. I think a useful search term also is recursion schemes. I've seen that used to refer to catamorphism, anamorphism. And the combo of catamorphism and anamorphism, I'm not sure which way around. Either way around, perhaps. It's called a hylomorphism, I believe.
这类算法被称为 cut，这个词可能越来越让我觉得顺眼了。我认为另一个有用的搜索词是 recursion schemes（递归方案）。我见过它被用来指代 catamorphism 和 anamorphism。而 catamorphism 和 anamorphism 的结合——我记不清是哪个在前了。无论哪个在前都行，我想它被称为 hylomorphism（含代数同态）。
A hylomorphism. Just a generalized data structure transformation. Yeah, I tried to understand it. And I think I did briefly for like a day. And then you gave me some example that helped but uh it's never stuck what that would have been yeah i only remember it because i think of it as like going high and then low again expanding and then reducing but yeah unfolds are very are. I can't remember what, we went back and forth via email. And then it was about iterate.
一种态射。只是一个广义的数据结构转换。对，我试着去理解它。我想我大概懂了一天。然后你给我举了个例子，挺有帮助的，但呃，它从来没留在脑子里，那会是什么样呢，对，我只记得它是先变大然后又变小，展开然后收缩，但对，unfold确实是……我记不清了，我们通过电子邮件来回讨论过。然后是关于iterate的。
And then I was saying one of the most common patterns is actually like a transform after an iota, like in both array languages and even in the last team I work on, Rapids. We use thrust heavily and they've got fancy iterators and they've got an iota iterator that's called counting iterator and then they've got a transform iterator and it really should be the other way around iota's a bad name uh i disagree i love iota and ben has a guinea pig named Iota. Sadly, no more.
然后我说过，最常见的模式之一其实就像在iota之后的转换，比如在数组语言中，甚至在我工作的上一个团队Rapids里。我们大量使用thrust，他们有很酷的迭代器，有一个叫计数迭代器的iota迭代器，还有一个转换迭代器，其实应该反过来，iota是个不好的名字，呃，我不同意，我非常喜欢iota，Ben有一只叫Iota的豚鼠。可惜，已经不在了。
Oh, no. I'm sorry to hear that. Rest in peace, Iota. Guinea pigs are great, but they only last... Somebody clip Connor saying, Rest in peace, Iota, and put it on the internet and use it against him. No, no. I still have Min element okay is she he getting up
哦，不。听到这个我很遗憾。安息吧，Iota。豚鼠很棒，但它们的寿命只有……有人把Connor说“安息吧，Iota”的那段剪下来，放到网上去并用来对付他吗？不，不。我还有Min element，好吧，它是他/她起身的吗
an age uh she's they're all she's because you can't mix sexes with guinea pigs it's bad times can you fix a guinea pig i don't think think you can fix a guinea pig. Oh, yeah, you can. Although, and it happens. Usually it's best to leave them alone if you can, but you can fix them, and especially if they become prone to cancer later in life, which guinea pigs don't nearly so much as something like rats. Yeah. But yeah.
一个年纪，呃，她是……它们都是，她是，因为你不能把不同性别的豚鼠混养，那样情况很糟。你能给豚鼠绝育吗？我觉得你不能给豚鼠绝育。哦，对，可以。虽然，这确实会发生。通常如果可以的话最好别管它们，但你可以给它们绝育，特别是如果它们在晚年容易患癌症的话——虽然豚鼠不像老鼠那样容易得癌症。对。不过，对吧。
But anyway. I'm learning about category theory. I'm learning about rodents. This is awesome. Oh, well, the cool fact about guinea pigs is that, like humans, they can't make their own vitamin C, you know, but unlike almost every other mammal you could name. And so when scientists were trying to figure out what caused scurvy,
但不管怎样。我在学习范畴论。我在学习啮齿动物。这太棒了。哦，对了，关于豚鼠的一个酷事实是，就像人类一样，它们无法自己合成维生素C，你知道的，但几乎所有你能叫得出名字的其他哺乳动物都能。所以当科学家们试图弄清楚是什么导致了坏血病时，
they – now, I don't know whether they noticed that guinea pigs also get scurvy or whether they just lucked out. But anyway, they chose guinea pigs as their lab animals. And that's the reason we call just generic lab animals guinea pigs now. Interesting. Wow. Look at that. Which guinea are guinea pigs named after? Someone told me, I think it was Papua New Guinea.
它们——现在，我不知道他们是注意到豚鼠也会得坏血病还是只是碰巧运气好。但无论如何，他们选择了豚鼠作为实验动物。这就是我们现在把普通的实验动物统称为“豚鼠”（guinea pigs）的原因。有趣。哇。你看。豚鼠是以哪个几内亚（guinea）命名的？有人告诉我，我想是巴布亚新几内亚。
I'm not sure. All right. Well, before we wrap things up. See, okay. So a final, I feel like I shouldn't have said reduce earlier because you all said reduce. I should have said for each. I should have said for each or transform, which is actually the most fundamental thing. Like 99 or let's say 95% of code out there is for eachs.
我不确定。好吧。在我们结束之前。看，好吧。所以最后，我觉得我刚才不应该说reduce，因为你们都说了reduce。我应该说for each。我应该说for each或者transform，这其实是最基础的东西。就像99%或者说95%的代码都是for each。
Yeah, because they don't know the algorithms. Maybe. And again, only on linear sequences, right? Only on something you can define a linear traversal well let's just as like sure but just assume that no because because like a 4h you can feed it in a sufficient uh iterator that can do a non-linear traversal like like it's it you combine it with you know some fancy iterator or range I think we're using different terms of different definitions of linear but
对，因为他们不懂算法。也许吧。而且话说回来，只针对线性序列，对吧？只针对那些你能很好地定义线性遍历的东西，好吧，就当是这样，但只是假设不，因为像4h（for each），你可以给它提供一个足够的、呃，能够做非线性遍历的迭代器，比如，它和一些很酷的迭代器或范围结合起来……我觉得我们对线性的定义和理解不同，但是
I mean what do you mean by linear here you just give it you know I mean you can have a two dimensional data structure like a like a map yeah like a red black tree the implementation but you can still define a linear iteration I mean you know you can a flattened iteration I mean I mean something you know, you can... A flattened iteration.
我的意思是，你这里说的线性是什么意思？你只是给它，你知道的，我的意思是你可以有一个二维的数据结构，比如像一个map，像红黑树的实现，但你仍然可以定义线性迭代，我的意思是，你知道的，你可以进行扁平化迭代，我的意思是，我的意思是某种，你知道的，你可以……扁平化迭代。
I mean, something will start at the beginning, and when it comes to the end, it will stop. Okay, sure. Something that will... Without a nested hierarchy. It can traverse, you know, like you can have a pre-order, post-order, in-order traversal of a tree, right? That's a linear traversal in the sense that it visits every element.
我的意思是，某种从头开始的东西，当它到达末尾时，它会停止。好吧，当然。某种会……没有嵌套层级的东西。它可以遍历，你知道的，就像你可以对树进行前序、后序、中序遍历一样，对吧？就它访问每个元素而言，那是一种线性遍历。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm not saying like like a 4h that like necessarily visits it well it depends on what you define as the element right you could you can you can you know instead of feeding it in a sequence of every element in the data structure you can feed it in a sequence of just the elements that you selected or things like that. Sure. I mean, yeah, the algorithm itself is a linear algorithm. It happens to be working on an iterator that encapsulates the non-linearity. Okay. That's the, I acknowledge your point.
对。对，我不是说像一个4h（for each）那样一定去访问它，这取决于你如何定义元素，对吧？你可以，你可以，你知道的，与其给它输入数据结构中每个元素的序列，不如只给它输入你选择的那些元素的序列诸如此类。当然。我的意思是，算法本身是一个线性算法。它碰巧运行在一个封装了非线性的迭代器上。好吧。这是个，我承认你的观点。
I acknowledge your point. Well, no, wait, I was going to say, I was like, before we wrap things up and then you interjected, Brycece i said we were the last thing we're gonna say is is there anything tristan ben things we want to randomly mention plug or just say to the listeners yeah attend your local meetup if you don't have a local meetup and for whatever reason you you can't start one or find one consider consider the denver meetup which is a hybrid meetup and now having said that our very next one will not be hybrid as it happens i was gonna say one of the best meetups out there because arguably the best in sense of well in whatever sense in sense, in North America. Yeah. Many, many well-known speakers and good talks that I've seen in the past, including Ben, of course.
我承认你的观点。好吧，不，等等，我本来想说，我是说，在我们结束之前，然后你打断了，Bryce，我说我们要说的最后一件事是，Tristan、Ben，有什么我们想随机提及、宣传一下或者对听众说的话吗？去参加你们当地的聚会吧，如果没有当地的聚会，而且无论出于什么原因你无法发起或找到一个，考虑一下丹佛聚会，这是一个混合聚会，话虽如此，我们的下一个聚会恰好不会是混合的，我本来想说，这是最好的聚会之一，可以说是北美最好的聚会，从某种意义上说，无论从什么意义上说。对。我过去见过许多知名的演讲者和精彩的演讲，当然也包括Ben。
Tristan, you've got the local London meetup as well. We have. We have run by Phil Nash, which is excellent. And anybody who's in London, it's not a hybrid, but the talks are recorded and Phil puts them up on the YouTube channel afterwards. Someone got in there before you, Bryce. Sorry, there's just this other podcast host that I like better. But Connor and I have this exciting, you know,
Tristan，你也有当地的伦敦聚会。我们有。我们有，由Phil Nash运营，非常棒。任何在伦敦的人，虽然不是混合聚会，但演讲都会被录下来，Phil事后会把它们放到YouTube频道上。有人抢在你前面了，Bryce。抱歉，只是我更喜欢另一个播客主持人。不过Connor和我有一个令人兴奋的，你知道的，
this exciting little bit of travel that we're going to do, which I think will be a pretty unique experience. Your road trip. The pot on the road. Yeah. Will we crash? It should probably be a lot more planned than it is currently planned. No, it's all good.
这个激动人心的小旅行，我们即将开启，我认为这将是一次非常独特的体验。你们的公路旅行。路上的播客。对。我们会车祸吗？它可能应该比目前计划的要做更多的计划。不，一切都好。
We got the flights. That's all that matters. Yeah. And you got the car rental. Yeah. Connor, you're going to be driving. Is that right? I'm going to be driving. driving he's gonna have the mic but you're gonna be driving and podcasting oh absolutely we're
我们订了机票。这才是最重要的。对。你们还租了车。对。Connor，你要开车。是这样吗？我要开车。他要开车，他会有麦克风，但你要开车并录播客。哦，当然，我们要
gonna at least record one or two podcasts while driving we're definitely gonna get pulled over by the slovenian or no no that's not illegal that's not that can't be illegal that's not why we're gonna get pulled over we're gonna get pulled over for driving erratically your tombstone is gonna say killed the environment so yeah you're gonna fly back across the atlantic for two days and then fly yeah back to europe yeah i i want to be home to see my family even if it's just for a couple days do you offset your carbon footprint somehow Bryce? Nope. Question, which conferences are coming up for each of us? In particular is there a chance Tristan
至少在开车时录一两个播客。我们绝对会被斯洛文尼亚警察拦下来，或者——不，不，那不是非法的，那不可能非法，那不是我们要被拦下来的原因。我们要因为开车歪歪扭扭而被拦下来。你的墓碑上会写着：杀死环境的主谋。所以，对，你要飞回大西洋彼岸呆两天，然后飞——对，飞回欧洲。对，我想回家见我的家人，哪怕只呆几天。Bryce，你用什么方式抵消你的碳足迹吗？没有。请问，我们每个人接下来都有哪些会议？特别是，Tristan，我们今年有没有可能
that you and I will be attending the same conference this year at all? On my radar I've got C++1C and CPP North where you will be delivering a keynote. Thank you so much to Tristan and Ben for coming on the podcast to talk everything about algorithms. We look forward to seeing them at a future conference.
在同一个会议上见面？在我的雷达图上有C++1C和CPP North，你将在那里发表主题演讲。非常感谢Tristan和Ben来到播客畅谈算法的一切。我们期待在未来的会议上见到他们。
Be sure to check the show notes in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion for any comments, thoughts, or questions that you might have. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目说明或访问ADSPthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何链接，以及指向GitHub讨论区的链接，以便发表你可能有的任何评论、想法或问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。